today's topic for Action investigation a
31 year old woman who admits to having
sex with a 13 year old boy and then
becoming pregnant with his child won't
face any jail time under a plea deal
with prosecutor Adam Serrano gave birth
to a baby boy she admitted to having sex
with that 13 year old the victim's
mother who were not going to identify in
this story tells us she is not happy
with this deal offered to a woman she
says ruined her son's life
okay
what's the deal no jail time for and you
do and you do what well they're probably
gonna do probation they're probably
gonna do something supervised you're on
offenders list I didn't know you could
be on the offender's list and have a
child first thing for
am I the only one that thinks that's
kind of weird
imagine being put on an offenders list
and also being allowed to keep your kid
is that a thing
I mean if the offender is a woman
I may be unaware I actually don't know
how this [__] works
that's crazy because there's plenty of
offenders I'm pretty sure who do get to
keep their kids yeah okay okay
first thing first you have to understand
one thing that pops up in their mind it
was sexual even though if there was
intercourse and it was a kid because uh
in the law for certain people for
certain States for certain places uh
it's only a man that can great
it's only meant again you know
and since it was consensual or whatever
wait wait you just said all that but I
actually don't even know is that true
are you sure in some place well because
of the because of the way the law is
made because it's written that it's a
penis right but it's not that's not like
that in America it depends on the places
I think it's like penetration is what
they Define as and but penetration by
what because if it's because if it's not
the member of so if it's fingers it's
not going to be considered great because
it's if it's fingers it's not great for
some in some places it has to be penis
okay I mean I'll take it but or you
could you could I'll take your word for
it's fine depending on where you are so
it can change so there's that so it
wasn't saw like if she would if it was a
man doing that it would have been a
whole lot of charges so and then after
that no jail time is a mess bro
yeah like I can't
I mean you have to imagine
it's 13 year olds at school
even Peewee and jelly at lunch Tim how's
your son
that's wild you don't even as a 13 year
old like
that's crazy to be a dad yeah you don't
even eat your own you don't even you
don't even do your own lunches but
you're gonna eat your teacher's lunch
that's crazy
you know what else 13. if she gets to
keep the kid think about this think
about this think about that
that being said that being said
the grandma wants to see her grandchild
she got a visit her child's greatest
Barbados in coconuts by the water I was
picking coconuts in Barbados yeah
you're foul that being said coconuts by
the
that being said
um this is actually a serious topic but
I just can't but no think about it
though you want to see your grandchild
you got to go see your child's rapist
yeah your child want to see their kid
they gotta work out an agreement which
well it's gonna be what's on the grandma
because she's gonna be the one who's
gonna have to do a lot of this middle
meaning but that is insane she has
[__] up this kid's life in so many
ways
forget childhood it's like he's a kid
having to raise a kid
but he's not even ready to raise a kid
like he's never going to go through that
18 to 24 year old phase where he's
figuring life out he got a he got to be
a parent right away already one crazy
thing to do that to to not even wear
protection to not even do that like to
to [__] up his life that way and for her
to get zero jail time my girl you are
sick and demented my girl
There's issues there there's issues she
[__] up his life she [__] his life
up and whoever the prosecutor is like
this is a Smoking Gun she's too old you
got the you got this worm this is what I
suspect I think the reason why they did
the plea deal and this is my suspicion
is because who's going to take care of
the kid yeah
I can't go to jail I can't go I can't
birth the kid in jail and I can't uh to
get like I gotta attack again that's the
only thing because if this was a woman I
don't think they would if this is a man
who had done this I don't think they
would have shown him anything no of
course not so I think it's because of
that
she is not happy with this deal offered
to a woman she says ruined her son's
life
I feel like my son's robbed of his
childhood now he's having to be a father
and he's a victim and he's gonna have to
live with that for the rest of his life
this mother says watching her son
struggle with the reality he now faces
breaks her heart what has this been like
for your son
um caused him a lot of depression he's
shut down a lot now she questions why
this woman won't face prison time I feel
like if she was a man and he was a
little girl it would definitely be
different they would be seeking
incarceration and I feel like because
she's a woman they're not they're having
compassion for her because she was
pregnant but I don't think they take
into play again she was pregnant by a
child
you know that child was created from a
sexual abuse under terms of the plea
deal the suspect signed off on she'll be
required to register as a sex offender
and the judge could sense her to 10
Years to Life of sex offender intensive
supervised probation but Serrano will
avoid any jail time since the DA's
office dropped the original charges to a
lesser charge that does not come with
mandatory jail time should other parents
be looking for
anybody honestly I mean you can't trust
anybody now
the victim's family says they are
looking for the next step house was the
victim
because the prosecutor is not trying to
do that no but the thing that happened
is if she's not if she doesn't get
custody of the kid
that's why I walk your ass to jail walk
your ass to jail I'm not changing the
plea deal no they're not gonna they're
not gonna change that once it's made I'm
just saying the victim's family says
they are looking for the next steps in
this case and they'll actually ask the
courts to give custody to the 13 year
old of this baby Adam and Lindsay what
we do know is that Serrano has a hearing
coming up in May where she will learn
how much probation time she'll have
currently Serrano has full custody of
the baby back to you that is crazy
this story it might be the most crazy
story I think I've read on this channel
imagine being able to Grape someone get
out of jail because you're pregnant and
also get to keep the baby as a defender
of underage oh baby baby it's a wild
world
any thoughts
go ahead hit him
what do you want me to say at this point
there's so much things and so much depth
in this just the fact that she's a woman
yeah please please in part the fact that
they like yeah she has good staff
custody of the kid the whole ass
offender
that's like sometimes these sword makes
you think am I the only one that sign
and see that there's a problem in there
they don't see the problem
they just think it's
okay
what you looking for choosing any more
info
which is crazy now we don't know what
was the relationship like I assume it
was a teacher right they didn't mention
that but they didn't mention that so
it's probably not even the teacher and
when the mother said yo she had neck
tattoos I don't think she's a teacher
yeah and then she said you can't shut up
you can't you can't you can't trust
nobody so it's possible that someone
close to the generally is yeah generally
someone close it's just I don't know
I can't I don't know wait wait wait wait
wait run that [__] back
her name is Serrano okay they didn't say
the name of the kid okay cool you know
okay I thought the accident I think
they're probably just not mentioning how
she met him or whatever to protect the
kids yeah exactly because they're child
they're minor uh and it doesn't really
matter I think the other day most people
who offend do it to people close to them
that's how vast like 95 of all these
things goes rarely strangers so that's
why she probably said you can't trust
nobody because it's in relation to that
but I don't know
I mean at some point you got to stop
just completely um the world's unfair I
think people know so it's just one of
those things where
apparently you you can rape a Todd and
if you get pregnant by them you might
get off and that is crazy
nah man it's just great I'm just trying
to find something on the mom on the mom
on the on the perpetrator